dr lindsey burke is the director of the
center for education policy at the
heritage foundation
and the mark a collocotrones fellow in
education policy i'm sure that i
mispronounced that lindsay thank you so
much for coming on the show
thanks for having me so first question
joe biden says i'm going to forgive all
these student loans nancy pelosi back in
april says the president doesn't have
the right to forgive all of these
student loans
who's right
well look i never thought i would say
this but i have to agree with nancy
pelosi there was a legal memo from the
office for general counsel at the
department of ed two years ago that said
that the secretary does not have the
statutory authority to cancel compromise
discharge or forgive on a blanket or
mass basis principal balances of student
loans that's pretty clear-cut and so i
think they are on dubious legal grounds
and i'm confident we'll see some
challenge moving forward
now what will the effect of that
challenge be because i'm reminded of
andrew jackson and justice marshall you
know marshall make gives his decree from
the supreme court and andrew jackson may
or may not have said justice marshall
has given his judgment now let's see him
enforce it so sure maybe we get a legal
challenge maybe some court comes and
says okay biden doesn't have the right
to do that well
when is that going to occur how long
after he's already practically speaking
forgiven all the student loans
right well this is an open question
right now and i don't think we know the
answer but what we do know is that what
happened yesterday with the
administration now planning to
forgiveness is a misnomer right they're
just shifting the debt onto all american
taxpayers but this plan is going to
further inflate college costs it's going
to hinder economic growth it's going to
reward upper income earners and of
course it's going to provide a major
handout to these woke institutions of
higher education and it really is just
the epitome of unfair policy because so
many individuals made a conscious
decision not to attend college to avoid
exactly this debt and yet they're being
handed somebody else's bill so it really
is just foisting somebody else's debt
onto all american taxpayers and
forcing middle-income americans who did
not or could not attend college to pay
off the loans that somebody else took
out so it really is it's just a height
of unfair policy but isn't there a
response that we'll get from the libs
here which is
conservatives talk all the time about
how the rich pay pretty much all of the
taxes in america and people who graduate
from a four-year college are more likely
to make more money and so
yes as a matter of optics you you have
the majority of americans who don't go
to college or graduate from a four-year
college uh paying off the student loans
of this minority of americans who do
graduate from a four-year college and
tend to make more money but practically
speaking it's probably just the college
graduates paying off these these bills
anyway right because the college
graduates are more likely to be wealthy
yeah more likely to repay but i think
there are so many moral hazards that
this is creating that is going to throw
all of this out of whack moving forward
why would anybody ever pay on their
loans again right now you are currently
getting what is effectively an
interest-free loan due to this pause on
repayments and then massive chunks of
loan balances are being transferred on
to somebody else so why would you save
why would you contribute to your kids
529 why would you plan on repaying in
the future and then of course it goes
without saying but universities are
going to capture all of this largesse
they're going to increase tuition moving
forward because they know these federal
subsidies are likely to continue in the
future and then students are going to
borrow the maximum amount that they can
and likely attend a more expensive
university than they would have
otherwise in anticipation that their
loans will be forgiven in the future and
i i think one frequently overlooked
aspect of this is the continued pause on
repayments this pause as expensive as
the so-called forgiveness is we know
it's going to cost at least 570 billion
dollars as expensive as that is the
pause on repayments is costing 5 billion
per month and that was just extended
through december through the end of
december so this is not only incredibly
expensive but the pause is probably the
most regressive component because
doctors and lawyers are benefiting the
most from not having that interest
accrue on their high levels of student
loan debt what do you think the end game
is here do you think that this is just
an old
you know chicago machine style pay off
the voters that you want to vote for you
in november or is this part of a broader
strategy to make college free for
everybody as some of the more left-wing
democrats have been campaigning on for
years
well i think it's a little bit of both
you have to ask yourself why this
particular type of debt right there is
so much debt out there for so many
things beyond college right the
owner operator truck driver who took out
a 150 000 loan to be able to buy his own
rig so that he could earn more down the
road why should he have to pay off the
student loan of a college-going
counterpart who statistically speaking
could earn more than him down the road
you know why not the debt of the auto
loan of the uber driver right somebody
had tweeted you know my mortgage now
identifies as a student loan so there
are so many different types of debt that
are out there it begs the question why
this particular type and i think the
only answer is because this is a
politically favorable constituency but
you're also right and that this is the
first step toward what the left
ultimately wants which is free higher
education to really extend the k-12
system into a k-16 system which of
course accrues to the bottom line of
teachers unions and the left broadly
this army of diversocrats that are now
employed in both higher ed and k-12
education i'm really torn on what to do
about it because i know that a lot of
conservatives say college is stupid
don't go and it is not lost on me that
while we have lots of people at the
daily wire with lots of very fancy
college degrees
the the three people who have ever
signed my paycheck
not one of them has a college degree
they all the people at the very very top
did not go to college and just sort of
worked very hard and were very smart and
uh created a very successful company and
then the people who received the checks
we all went to the fancy schools and you
know the big name brand universities so
i'm i'm
not suggesting that you have to go to
college to make a lot of money and
actually some of the most interesting
entrepreneurs
have dropped out or didn't go at all
but all of that said
i think college
can be good i really like liberal
education i break with the conservatives
who say
people should just study engineering
study something useful to help you get a
job i think that's insane i think the
only reason you should go to college is
to read dusty old books of poetry i
think you should never take a practical
vocational class in college there's
vocation training and trade schools for
that the point of a liberal education is
to make sense of your freedom cultivate
your
your cultivate culture and and you know
know about your culture and you know
train your rational will and so
i really want to support college and
liberal education specifically on the
one hand and then on the other i look on
the campuses and i say people aren't
getting that anywhere i mean they're not
getting that at harvard they're not
getting that anywhere in america so
what do we do about that yeah
yeah you're right and we have created an
incentive structure that tells young
americans that their only way to climb
the path of upward economic mobility in
america is through a four-year brick and
mortar college and i agree with you we
have sold higher education purely in in
economic terms and really focused on
some of what should be the domain of
trade schools and apprenticeship
programs and so i think i'm 100 with you
there is all the value in the world and
getting a liberal arts education but
right now we're at a point where the
federal government the federal taxpayer
is financing they're originating and
servicing and directly providing 93
percent of all student loans
and so when that whatever choice doesn't
pay off for an individual student and
they default or more of this loan
forgiveness debt shifting occurs that
means the burden is being borne by
american taxpayers there is no bank that
is picking up the tab for this the bank
is me and you it's the american taxpayer
and so every incentive that is
you know part of the higher education
structure right now is out of whack from
the financing to what is being taught to
the way that universities spend their
money and speaking of harvard harvard is
sitting on an endowment of over 50
billion dollars if they really cared
about the plight of students you know
these poor harvard law grads then they
would tap into that endowment and help
lower the cost of tuition
now that's such a good point and it my
inner communist comes out when i look at
these schools that are playing a large
role in the destruction of our country
and i just say seize the endowments eat
the rich let's go let's do it but you're
doing it to us let's do it to these guys
so i i
i totally
i totally feel that
now i've got this argument that i would
often make to conservatives when they
ask me should i go to college and i say
most cases probably not
and for most colleges probably not
now that's a harder argument to make
because one of the chief arguments
against going to college is you're going
to take out a quarter million dollars in
debt and you're not going to really have
a lot to show for it other than you went
to some fun parties for four years you
did a lot of stuff you shouldn't do and
you're probably more ignorant than you
were when you started
now though
if college is
either going to be greatly reduced in
cost or practically free because people
they can take out as much debt as they
want they can expect not to pay it back
then why shouldn't students go to
college and have a fun party for four
years and not have to pick up the tab
yeah exactly i mean this is all part of
the moral hazard that this has created
people will make sub-optimal decisions
that they would not otherwise have made
because of this free money that is now
out there associated with higher
education and if we take a step back we
know what happens when countries try to
make college free at the point of
delivery they end up having to ration
seats we saw this in the united kingdom
in the 90s and then they eventually
reinstituted tuition fees because they
didn't want to have to ration seats and
so we know when big government gets
involved with trying to finance and to
provide higher education subsidies at an
even greater rate that all of these bad
incentives are created not the least of
which is that universities are going to
continue increasing tuition if you look
over the past 30 years we know that
total federal aid has increased about
300 percent
what did universities do in response
they more than doubled their tuition in
real terms and of course this is what
they're going to continue to do we've
known that for a long time it's the old
bennett hypothesis that reagan's
education secretary put forward all the
all the way back in 1987 and that has
really turned i think into a truism and
you know last thing on that there was a
study that the new york federal reserve
bank put out a few years ago that found
that for every additional dollar in
subsidized student loans universities
raised their tuition about 60 cents
in other words they're just capturing
all of these additional subsidies and
they're not passing it along to students
in the form of reduced tuition or
increased salaries they're hiring
additional dei staff or amassing more
real estate so they're not spending it
in a responsible way and we're likely to
see that continue do you think that in
the short term this political gamble
will work i'm talking about midterm
elections
biden and the dems are underwater on
pretty much every single issue kovids
sometimes they pop above sea level but
not very often
so
this is it they're trying to buy a bunch
of votes
does it work
look i think it's a numbers game i mean
we have to keep in mind that only
one-third of americans have bachelor's
degrees
far far fewer have graduate degrees and
so that third you know if he's not
winning over votes among that third
which that could be a third where he was
already doing pretty well
i don't think that it's actually going
to move the needle very much
most americans look at this and say this
is incredibly unfair i either worked my
way through college or i graduated
college and lived modestly so that i
could repay my student loans that i
agreed to pay back
i didn't go out to fancy dinners or you
know didn't go on european vacations i
mean this is what i think the average
american taxpayer is thinking right now
and if you scrimped and saved to pay for
your college or to pay for the college
of your child
and all of a sudden you're seeing the
biden administration with a stroke of
the pen by the way what is probably
going to be the most expensive stroke of
a pin in history just hand somebody
else's debt to you after you responsibly
saved or responsibly paid off your
student loans
that is just the most frustrating thing
you can imagine so i think that they
have underestimated how this will
ultimately play out in november
you know it does feel a little bit like
late stage empire i know conservatives
always want to compare everything to the
fall of of rome but it does feel a
little bit like that moment you see at
the end of empires where people are just
plundering the treasury as they say well
if i don't take the money the other
guy's going to take it and
when that happens
political problems can accelerate very
quickly uh lindsay thank you so much for
coming on the show people uh can find
you i i take it at the heritage
foundation anywhere else on social media
that's right i'm at lindsay m burke you
can also find me at the educational
freedom institute as well excellent
that's wonderful lindsay i can't wait
when we have you back on next time i
assume it will be you know amid the
ruins of american america's educational
system and we can figure out where to go
from there lindsay thank you for coming
on
thanks for having me right now head on
over to rockauto.com
the value of your minivan pickup sedan
whatever you drive probably appreciated
pretty significantly last year
that's the silver lining amid all the
crazy supply chain stuff and the record
inflation means you got to take care of
your automotive investment keep more of
your money by buying the auto parts that
you need to maintain and repair your
vehicle at rockauto.com
rockauto.com has been in the auto parts
business for 20 years
it's family owned super easy to navigate
catalog always reliably low prices no
gimmicks you just you're not going to
beat their price anywhere doesn't matter
the day of the week same prices for pros
and do it yourselfers i've told you
about my buddy i'm gonna shame him again
my buddy who he really likes rock auto
but he was he was just feeling a little
loose one day he goes to the brick and
mortar auto parts store he just wanted
to get a part
they find the part finally they wanted
to charge him 400 bucks he pulls up rock
auto it was 150 on rock auto he said you
you scammers you're trying to rip me off
over here i'm going back to rock auto go
to rockauto.com get brakes shocks carpet
wipers headlights mirrors mufflers lug
nuts or any other part that you need
rockauto.com be sure to write knowles
k-w-l-e-s and then how did you hear
about his box so they know that we sent
you
i'm glad you like that clip now look we
have over a million subscribers i want
one quintillion i do and i'm not gonna
stop until i get it so ring that bell
subscribe we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]